séquence ping pong je reçois manuel
valls il va répondre à une critique de
claude cabanes de l'humanité à propos de
son ouvrage sécurité la gauche peut tout
changer et c'est aux éditions du moment
manuel valls bonsoir bonsoir à vous et
député ps de l'essonne maire vivre et
alors on peut se demander si ce livre
c'est un programme pour un futur
candidat aux primaires socialistes
est ce que c'est le cas non c'est un
coup de coeur il m'arrive d'écrire j'ai
déjà publié la dernière un livre sur
l'exercice du pouvoir et une vision plus
générale de ce que doit être la
politique dans ce pays
mais là j'ai voulu partir
essentiellement à travers mon rôle de
mère d'expériences de rencontres
notamment avec des victimes mais aussi
avec des policiers avec des juges avec
des gens qui travaillent à la pjj et des
jeunes donc j'ai c'est à partir de ces
expériences personnelles de redonner
aussi une vision plus générale de ce que
doit être le rapport de l'autorité et de
l'ordre leur apporte de la gauche avec
ces deux concepts alors je vais lire la
dédicace reculer les premières lignes
qui sont très révélatrices du ton du
livre ce livre je le dédie à celles et à
ceux pour qui chaque matin sortir de
chez soi les travail et prendre l'air
s'habille en jute courir dans un parc ne
va pas de soi je le dédie à celles et
ceux pour qui le soir pénétrez dans un
parking traverser le pont qui les
ramènent chez eux est devenue une
appréhension et tout de suite j'ai pensé
oh
la france a peur de gicquel vous
souvenez de cette c'était dans d'autres
conditions dramatiques c'était un
patrick henry c'était l'histoire d'un
petit enfant qui avait été assassiné
mais le ton est un ton un peu
dramatisant non il ya une france qui a
peur
incontestablement quand des citoyens
quelles que soient leurs conditions
sociales leurs couleurs leurs origines
ont peur de rentrer on l'appréhension la
boule au ventre de rentrer dans leur
hall d'immeuble ou de prendre un
transport ou de rentrer tard le soir
c'est qu'il ya quelque chose qui ne va
pas dans notre société et le fait que ce
soit quelqu'un de gauche qu'ils disent
qu'ils partent de ses expériences
ça doit être plutôt rassurant et ça
montre que la gauche est en capacité de
2 d'essayer de répondre à dit laurent
blanc si vous voulez dire que de toute
façon il y aura ce qu'il faut mourir oui
mais parce que nier la réalité c'est
déjà s'empêcher d'être écouté par ceux
qui ont envie que les responsables
politiques répondent à ces à ses
angoisses même si eux mêmes savent que
c'est difficile et je le dis d'ailleurs
dans le livre pas de démagogie
il faudra du temps pour reconstruire les
conditions de la confiance dans ces
quartiers vous parlez d'un basculement
mental nécessaire presque idéologique et
mentale rire bien sûr oui parce que la
gauche est à la fois la révolte là la
liberté la volonté de bousculer l'ordre
mais en même temps l'ordre c'est un
élément essentiel parce que le désordre
c'est la loi de la jungle et qui sont
les victimes de la loi de la jungle
c'est en général les plus faibles les
plus modestes delà de la société et moi
ces gens là qui ont voté à gauche ou qui
ne votent plus ou qui ont été tentés par
le vote au front national ces femmes qui
se font agresser la dans un but cela
dans un dans un parc
ces pompiers ou six agents de la poste
qui sont victimes d'agressions parfois
très violentes dans les quartiers
s'étaient eux aussi que je veux parler
mais sans démagogie sent flatté parfois
les instincts deux heures les de la
révolte de l'être humain face à ces
injustices mais leur parler manière
rationnelle mais à leur dire que nous on
va les entendre et qu'on va leur
proposer des solutions alors je donne
l'occasion de parler avec claude cabanes
qui attend alors si eric cottier ban a
publié éloge de la vulgarité aux
éditions
durocher donc prenons la parole à pau
tiemann bonsoir camarades fall ce jeu
avant même de lire le moindre la moindre
ligne de ton livre je me permet de
tutoyer
j'avais déjà un mouvement de sympathie
vers toi d'une part parce que nous
sommes du même peuple le peuple de
gauche d'autre part parce que tu es
d'origine espagnole et que quand j'étais
petit garçon dans mon village du gers
alors pourquoi je vous demande d'arrêter
parce que dans votre ligne apparaît ce
qui m'a beaucoup intéressé sur la
référence à vos origines espagnoles vous
avez été naturalisé à l'âge de 20 ans et
vous parlez de votre père vous dites mon
père il était artiste et anti franquiste
et c'est mon socle et on a le sentiment
que tout ce que vous êtes repose sur ce
soft mais manuel valls vous savez que
c'est difficile pour beaucoup d
individus aujourd'hui d'avoir un soap
tel que celui là oui c'est sûr mais
c'est une c'est une c'est une chance moi
j'ai ne doublent une triple culture la
culture espagnole et catalane qui est
très fort ma mère et culture italienne
et en même temps j'ai tout appris de la
france et de l'école et je considère que
vivre avec plusieurs cultures tout en
partageant les mêmes valeurs de notre
pays ce n'est pas l'heure de la
république ça devrait ça doit être un
atout valoriser et je sais combien de
deux gamins ne se sentent ni français ni
appartenant à leur culture de leurs
parents parce qu'il n'y a pas eu ni
transmission ni de respect de ces
cultures alors il ya beaucoup choix que
je partage dans leur livre par exemple
je partage complètement la nourrice que
tu fais de la politique de nicolas
sarkozy quant à la sécurité
d'autres jeux je vais vite quand tu dis
c'est une boutique de communication qui
a fait un fiasco général politique de la
ville fiasco général
donc je partage voyez d'accord avec moi
parce que je critique déjà nicolas
sarkozy c'est
c'est un bon point au passé est ce que
c'est le plus petit dénominateur commun
pour vous la critique de sarkozy parce
que que le fait que ce soit moi qui l'
souligne qu'il ait jamais versé dans
l'anti sarkozysme qui vit cette réalité
comme mère ça crédibilise une critique
même si évidemment on ne gagne pas une
élection uniquement par la critique et
le rejet surtout quand on aspire à
gouverner
vous devez être à ça doit pas vous
plaire quand on vous classe comme sarko
compatible non mais je ne le suis pas il
m'a proposé de rentrer dans son
gouvernement
il y a quatre ans mais moi je suis
fidèle à mes valeurs je crois pas à
l'ouverture
et puis je savais que ce plan économique
ou même sur le plan de la sécurité
il allait échouer on est quand même dans
un drôle de pays où le dialogue est
difficile c'est bon on est obligé dure
beaucoup de mal de l'autre on doit être
respecté dans son propre camp non ça
marche pas tout à fait comme ça je crois
pas alors je vais te des halles il ya
quelque chose de plus grave pour moi
c'est que tu parles de la querelle entre
clemenceau et jaurès jaurès le fondateur
le socialisme le fondateur de mon
journal l'humanité et tu dis moi je
choisis clemenceau contre jaurès
tu dis je choisis l'ordre contre la
justice
je ne suis pas de ton côté la manière
naturelle
évidemment je dis pas ça mais il ya un
débat extraordinaire comme on n'en voit
plus entre entre jaurès pour qui j'ai
une immense admiration
le fondateur de l'humanité effectivement
qui a aidé à la loi de 1905 sur la
laïcité avec beaucoup d'humanité qui a
compris mieux que clemenceau quelle
était la question sociale de ceux de
ceux de ce pays mais un débat à
l'affrontement et l'affrontement il est
sur l'exercice du pouvoir et clemenceau
lui réponds parce que lui les présidents
du conseil les ministres de l'intérieur
pendant toute cette pluie à pons moi je
me coltine l'exercice du poids vous
faites de ce genre est ce très grand
discours il bâtissait
des palettes féerie moi je ne suis que
l'un simple ouvrier qui construit des
cathédrales mais vous ça va s'évaporer
et et moi je construis et au fond ce but
le partage non mais j'évoque cela parce
qu'on peut être pour jaurès et pour
clemenceau mais là c'est l'essentiel
d'un vieux débat au sein de la gauche
entre ceux qui au fond considère que
l'exercice du pouvoir
c'est toujours un peu compliqué qu'on
est d'une certaine manière obligé de
renoncer à cette vidéo et ceux qui
considèrent que c'est pas l'exercice du
pouvoir qu'on répond véritablement aux
aspirations populaires
tu reproche à ségolène royal sa formule
l'ordre juste
et tu réponds pour moi juste l'ordre
je suis pas d'accord les sociétés
d'ordre souvent sans les sociétés
profondément inégalitaire regarde ce qui
s'est passé en tunisie et en egypte
l'ordre régnait et sous l'ordre une
dévastation qui acquit à la prédation du
peuple des mafias des barbes qui tenait
tout donc je me méfie de l'ordre manuel
valls cantine et parce que j'ai juste
pour lire le le passage correspondant à
cet ordre juste j'ai longtemps cru que
l'ordre juste de ségolène royal était
une piste prometteuse
j'ai changé d'avis pour une raison
évidente le simple fait d'accoler au mot
ordre l'épithète juste l aveu
inconscient pour la gauche que l'ordre
sol est en lui-même vécu comme une
dérive une menace
claude cabanes l'illustrent parfaitement
parce que je suis pour l'ordre en france
dans mon pays je serai complices de ce
que
dictature il aurait pu prendre
d'ailleurs l'exemple mais c'est facile
de l'union soviétique qui est souvent
soutenu ono même d'ailleurs d'une
certaine idée de leur nom bien
évidemment et l'ordre et la liberté
l'ordre et la démocratie l'ordre et la
participation des citoyens à l'exercice
du pouvoir vont totalement de pernes et
et le mot ordre juste qu'ils étaient
bien vu à ce moment là qui montrait déjà
une évolution que ségolène a bien porté
est ce que dit le cabanon qui a au sein
de la gauche toujours un débat une
difficulté à assumer totalement la
question de l'heure quand on l'assumé
totalement
on est au clair aussi sur le reste quand
on est de gauche sont idéales c'est
quand même de changer les choses de
changer la vie de ceux qui souffrent le
plus de changer la société pour qu'elle
soit plus harmonieuse plus juste et j'ai
l'impression que toi quelques autres la
tête du parti socialiste
vous avez renoncé à changer les choses
et vous voulez gérer les jeux et bien je
comprends que tu veuilles peut-être
devenir ministre l'intérieur ministre la
police si c'est pour changer les choses
dans la société français oui si c'est
pour gérer les choses telles qu'elles
sont non mon cher manuel
alors voulez vous toujours changer des
choses oui il faut changer le quotidien
des gens en leur disant la vérité aussi
nous sommes dans une économie de marché
dans un monde qui a beaucoup changé avec
des contraintes financières mais qu'on
peut changer que la politique remise à
sa vraie place
elle peut changer et on peut gouverner
et faire en sorte qu' on est une police
expérimenté fidéliser qui fasse son
métier dans les quartiers qui soit
respectueuse des valeurs et des droits
de la république qui ne tutoie pas les
les jeunes qu'ils aient un rapport avec
les citoyens ça c'est déjà changé
concrètement les choses
je crois qu'on a terminé avec kocaman
alors rappelé son texte
éloge de la vulgarité que cabane aux
éditions du rocher le vôtre manuel valls
sécurité la gauche peut tout changer aux
éditions du moment
je crois qu'on est entré dans une
période féconde pour les débats oui la
société française a besoin de débat elle
a besoin de sortir de cette difficulté à
ne pas débattre des vrais sujets merci
beaucoup commercial
[Musique]